i'm seeing stars playstation stars that
is learn all about playstation's new
rewards program as well as updates to
multiverses skate and rumbleverse all on
today's gamespot news
in its latest attempt to match xbox's
offerings playstation is instituting a
rewards program it is dubbing
playstation stars think of it like
challenges in a video game simply
logging on and playing will get you
rewards but there will be specific
campaigns and activities you'll be able
to complete for greater winnings these
bounties can then be cashed in for
things like psn wallet funds or items in
the playstation store ps plus
subscribers will also receive points for
making digital purchases playstation
will also be offering digital
collectibles which in this day and age
sounds a lot like nfts but sony's
playstation network head grace chen
assures us they're not chen told the
washington post quote it's definitely
not nfts definitely not you can't trade
them or sell them it is not leveraging
any blockchain technologies and
definitely not nfts wow
three definitely not sounds like players
have successfully scared off sony from
going anywhere near the blockchain we
did it great job gamers high five
early tests for playstation styles are
conducting as we speak with a full
rollout for every user later this year
the next skate is going to launch as a
free free-to-play title in an interview
with gamespot the game's creative
directors explained that the choice to
move to that model was made in order to
remove barriers to entry for anyone who
wants to experience the game skate will
be supported over time with content
drops such as new gameplay elements and
seasonal events and yes it will be cross
play and progression on pc and console
both current and previous gen as well as
an eventual mobile version of the game
the interview goes on to explain how
this new live service version of skate
retains the spirit of the original
titles as well as how it's evolved a
link to the interview is in the
description below multiverses the super
smash bros esque fighting game featuring
your favorite warner brothers characters
as well as for some reason a hybrid
reindeer dog called
rain dog is getting an open beta on july
26th with early access for may's closed
alpha participants starting july 19th if
you can't wait to fight as
rain dog you can also sign up for a shot
at early access via the game's website
multiverses follows nickelodeon's own
super smash clone nick allstars which
was heavily criticized at launch for
lacking voice acting a feature that
eventually came to the game multiverses
won't have that issue however as the
game's roster will be voiced by many of
the original actors that portrayed those
characters or their most iconic voices
such as matthew lillard shaggy who will
be in attendance with harley quinn's
voice actor tara strong at the
multiverses panel at san diego comic con
next week oh boy i hope raindog makes a
surprise appearance
if multiverses isn't your kind of verse
then maybe rumble verse will be much
like websites in the early 2000s
everyone has to have a verse of their
own if you don't have a verse you really
need to go get one right away the
wrestling themed battle royale allowing
40 players to duke it out in the
delightfully named grapple city will be
launching on august 11th the game first
shown off at last year's game awards was
indefinitely delayed from its original
february 15th release date to later in
2022 since then the game has gone
through a number of stress tests over
the months that followed which means
that it should hopefully launch in a
generally stable state when it enters
the ring next month and that is it for
today's game spot news if you want to
check out that skate interview or where
you can sign up for the open beta for
multiverses head to gamespot.com
you